i think the thing that people
misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get there
your goals don't count to their heart
the one thing all my athletes
in business in sports
the best of the best are so coachable
they're they listen
they listen they absorb the information
they pay attention
rise and shine it's espresso time hey
it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person but when you start your
day with a powerful routine that
inspires you like watching one of these
videos it can change your life so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee know that i believe in you
and get ready for a shot of espresso
from tim grover
[Music]
i think the thing that people
misunderstand about success
is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get there
you know and it's funny
how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promoted but had on your
show and everybody goes
five easy steps
ten steps to greatness yeah you know
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you gotta crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom it's crazy
all right what is that what does that
mean sometimes you're at the top and
then you're at the bottom again well you
may get to the top and you're like i'm
here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here
look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here
to get
i mean since starting this it's been
over eight years but the journey before
then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you obsess
exactly so all the steps that you
climbed just to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you when they pulled and they pulled
them off pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
that people that you thought that were
like hey these people
actually have my back except yeah they
did have your back but they were
actually pushing you down the steps
no
and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about it they seem
surprised
but you should know that in that path
all those things are going to be there
they're going to be there right
your goals don't count into their heart
your big ambitions your dreams your
desires the thing that you want to
create the life that you want to build
for yourself
everything great
comes with you putting in great amounts
of effort and work it's supposed to be
hard that's part of the thrill is that
you're putting in all of this effort and
something great comes out on the other
side if you didn't put work behind it
you wouldn't value it you wouldn't
appreciate it and so i think one of the
things that people really struggle with
is this whole working smart versus
working hard thing you work smart you
work hard a lot of people going against
hard work he said well just work smart
work smart work smart i'm all for
working smart it's both guys it's always
both it's both
you have to work smart of course and you
have to work hard hard work alone
is not enough there's plenty of people
who work incredibly hard and never come
anywhere close to reaching their goals
plenty of people
but just working smart alone that's not
enough either
hard work is your ticketing
hard work staying consistent doing the
thing is your ticket to the game
once you're inside the game now you got
to work smart it's always a combination
of both and so i don't think your goals
count
until they're hard until they're
difficult making videos for me it's it's
it's still difficult at the beginning it
was just getting comfortable in front of
the camera it was believing in myself it
was practicing having a message having a
story i would never have made a video in
the car with people walking by and the
windows open and never never i would
never have done that i would have been
too scared too shy too introverted too
worried about being judged never
so it was hard at the beginning but it's
still hard now because
youtube evolves youtube changes there's
new algorithms
now i'm doing multiple channels now
we're doing longer videos now they're
shorts now there's all of these things
that you have to constantly pay
attention to and that's fine
that's better than fine that's great
because my great goals my great
ambitions comes in the other side of me
doing a lot of great hard work
some people expect it to be easy
i think some people at the beginning we
buy into something to say oh well look
how easy it is for them it looks easy so
it's going to be easy for us i think
some people buy into it being easy but i
think
most of you
probably think okay it's not going to be
easy
it's going to be hard but you don't
expect it to be that hard i think this
is the problem
like you expect it to be hard but not as
hard as it actually is
i've made over 10 000 videos for my
channels
i would have thought that's crazy
i would i would have expected to work
hard but i would never said i'll make 10
000 videos it just seems like it's just
way too big a number how do you even go
and do that that's ridiculous that's too
hard i can't do that
and yet that's what it took
you know
so i think that becomes a problem is you
you don't expect to just get rich quick
you don't expect it to be easy you i'm
talking i'm not talking to america now
i'm talking to you you guys are
achievers you're part of believe nation
you don't expect it to be easy or handed
to you you're willing to put an effort
but you don't expect it to be that hard
to take more than your max effort
because you're putting in the work
and you're not getting the results
i know i know that sucks that was me my
first business putting in all the work
all the work all the work and just not
seeing the results and i just didn't i
expected to be hard but not this hard
not this hard and it pushes you to the
breaking point where you don't feel like
you can make it and i actually quit on
my business partner
for a day before coming back to it
because he didn't want to regret that
decision
i think it's something we all struggle
with especially at the beginning
especially when you're trying to build
momentum because because getting an
initial momentum getting the ball
rolling is the hardest part keeping
something in motion is a lot easier than
just getting something in motion at the
beginning
but you do have the strength
you find the strength
you find it buried inside you
and that thing that you're doing is so
important that you have to keep going
so how do you do it you know with great
that's a motivational little rant but
how do you actually do it let me give
you some strategies
step number one
is you remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you remind yourself you do difficult
things that when it gets difficult when
it gets scary when it gets hard you are
the person who does scary difficult
heart i use those as trigger words scary
difficult hard when i say those things
feel those things text those things
write those things
feeling those things then i have to do
it because evan carmichael does
difficult things you start to shift your
identity this isn't just an evan
carmichael thing this is a you thing
this isn't everybody who wants to
achieve things
that when it gets difficult you show up
you don't retreat you don't run away you
don't quit you don't stop when it gets
difficult you show up this is the time
to show up
you need you to show up
you do difficult things remind yourself
of it write it somewhere near your
computer write it by your bedside write
it on your bathroom mirror put it on
your fridge you do difficult things
wherever you go when you
feel the most down you know if you run
the food when you feel down great put it
on your fridge you do difficult things
the more you can remember that embrace
it live it
the more you're going to change your
life because when you are at your lowest
point
and you need that little boost just to
remind yourself of who you are what
you're made of so you don't allow those
negative situations to spiral out of
control that one setback leads to
a day a week a month of lack of
productivity you can't allow that to
happen setbacks will happen you cannot
control that
you can control your reaction to it and
it's okay to feel down for a few moments
it's okay to spend 15 minutes feeling
frustrated low down but not a day not a
week not a month not give up not throw
away your whole idea because of constant
setbacks the way to overcome the
setbacks is to overcome it's through
it's more continuous harder and smarter
work not to run away to feel sorry for
yourself to bury yourself netflix to
dream of a vacation right it's to
actually go through and do the difficult
things so step number one is you do
difficult things remind yourself of it
two
is project your life forward
the thing that really saved me when i
was when i quit on my business partner
was i would i would remember myself i
would imagine myself
being an old man at 40 i'm 41 now being
old man and it's over and life is
finished at 40.
and
i don't want to regret my life i don't
regret this decision i don't want to i
don't want to quit on this now i know
i'm going to regret and look back on my
life and say i wish i did more i wish i
tried more i wish i pushed harder i wish
i just gave it one more day one more
week from a month maybe that would make
maybe that would have my break and and i
did i mean that's what happened i
i quit on my business partner came back
the next day
and a couple weeks later had my first
deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars which
was life-changing for me at the time and
then and then you know i don't know a
year later
year and a half later sold the business
got acquired it's crazy how fast it
happened and i would have looked back
regretting that
so imagine you
you've already quit on some ideas that
if you just stuck with would have been
successful by now ideas that you had
three five years ago maybe even last
year that you you just stopped it had
tons of potential and you just stopped
you got discouraged you gave up you quit
that if you just kept going
three years is not that long a time
you've had ideas for a bunch of years if
you just kept going on it you'd be
somewhere by now right you'd be way
further ahead it would have turned into
something but you quit on it
the point of that isn't to to beat
yourself up the point is to use that as
fuel going forward to say okay the ideas
that you have right now
maybe it's still the same idea from
three years ago the ideas you've got
right now have potential
can be something
and if you don't continue on if you
don't keep throwing showing up not
throwing up
if you don't keep showing up throwing
down
there you go
you're gonna regret it you will regret
this you will regret
quitting right now you will request you
will regret throwing the towel you'll
regret it so remind yourself of it
jeff bezos calls it the regret
minimization framework
which is basically just try to live your
life with as few regrets as possible so
ask yourself will you regret this will
you regret not playing hard
you not showing up today in 40 years
will you regret it
and then step number three
is to
constantly be in the environment of the
things that empower you that inspire you
it's why i make these videos it's why i
have groups like movement makers
be around the things the people the
environment that lift you up that make
you want to go do those difficult things
that make you want to show up when
you're motivated full of energy on fire
it's easy to show up right it's easy to
show up it's easy to go and do your
thing it's easy to feel like everything
is possible and you're full of hope and
like yes it's easy to go and do it what
do you do in the days when you feel low
when when you when all the doubts and
insecurities creep in when you don't
feel like it's possible or someone like
you can't make it who were you to think
you could do this this is crazy you're
not getting results like those moments
that that you live in the self-doubt and
insecurity and the fear that just eat
away that just suck up productivity all
that time you spent thinking about how
crappy you are could be used actually
building a better life and business for
yourself just wasted time and effort
so what do you do in those moments you
have to be in the environment that that
pulls you back in that reminds you of
who you are and what you want to create
and what your potential is that makes
you actually feel like you have michael
jordan level genius at something so
whether that's these videos and i'm
honored to be a part of your daily
routine whether that's my other videos
whether that's my books or other
people's books and videos and podcasts
etc whether it's a natural community
like movement makers that you can join
or somebody else's community you can't
do this alone you can't do this by
yourself you can't stay stuck in this
environment because the people around
you right now are not pushing you to be
better
are not showing you a path to your great
life they're not and they're
you know there's probably lots of lovely
amazing humans around you amazing yes
great you're the one filling them up
who's doing that for you you have to be
around
the environment
that encourages you
and pushes you forward
when you
and the world around you is telling you
to stop to quit
to give up
do those three things your life will
change
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action
of when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you also
if you want to have more self-confidence
and self-belief the sign says it can
take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program where i'm going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming
stop resisting the natural flow of epic
performance everything i didn't want to
do
is what got me to where i'm at today if
you just pay attention to the details
you pay attention to the details you can
those distinguish those distinctions are
easy
are easy to see all right everybody
talks about working working hard showing
up early showing up late doing all
everybody can do that
everybody can do that it's the
mannerisms of the way they carry
themselves it's the way they compete
it's the way they listen it's the way
they absorb infra information how
coachable they are the one thing all my
athletes
in business in sports
the best of the best are so coachable
they're they listen
they listen they absorb the information
they pay attention they're there
they're willing they want that
information and they know the difference
between false information
and information that can actually work
for them you know kobe had a uh with the
first interview they did um with kobe
when they said oh yeah you're uh you
hired tim grover you hired mj guy you
know
uh what do you think about him he goes
he ain't done it for me yet i don't know
he's like yeah he did great things for
mj and he's done great things for other
things he ain't done nothing for me i
don't know
setting the tone
right there
how did you process that when you heard
that oh i just i i wouldn't expect
anything else i didn't do anything for
him yeah i didn't do anything and too
many people look at the history of what
they've done in the past they look at
their past wins their past their past
successes these individuals they've
always want they you could when you look
at that competitive person you can
always see with kobe i saw it very early
when
the in the um
playoffs in against utah when he shot
all those air balls at that you know he
was about 17 and always came in the
league at 70. so he was like 18 or 19
when he did that but
for most individuals that would have
just totally killed their confidence
how is he how did he come back how did
he handle it did he run from the
adversity did he run from the media what
did he do no he came back and owned what
he did
and says i'm coming back i'm coming back
for more i'm coming back for more for mj
it was just never forgetting
that he got cut from the varsity team
when he tried out as a sophomore when's
the best time for the truth
all the time
it's the best time for the truth all the
time the truth should lead to more
action
but what does it usually do it leads to
more emotions
wow
that's really true so when you tell
somebody the truth so what's the first
thing anybody in a relationship you go
in a relationship with
business personal whatever it is the
first thing they always ask me
honesty honesty is the most important
until you're honest well you know what
we in the book relentless we talk about
the don't think concept your skills are
so finely
good at what you do whether it's trading
making business decisions playing
basketball that you know the net if you
do fail at something it's just this
little stumbling block the next time
you're going to succeed because you've
done it over and over over again not
only physically but your mental
preparation the thing that makes
individuals really really special who
are that great is
they're always looking for that
competitive edge
so it's
interesting to see how a champion in
sports
how it relates to a champion in business
it's the same mindset
it's about winning the battles
continuing to improve
learning news ways to stay ahead uh stay
ahead of the game
clarity is what gives you the idea of
success being able to close those deals
when you can see
and you can think and you can react with
a clear mind
and your take your emotions out of it
you're in that zone getting the deal is
just a it's just a byproduct and the
minute you get the deal
you're already thinking about what's
next when you want to excel at something
what must you have did i just hear
somebody say passion in the audience you
know what passion is
passion is an emotion it's an emotion
without an action passion will get you
nowhere inner drive will get you nowhere
unless you act on it you have to act on
your passion you have to act on your
inner drive don't let those feelings
stay inside of you you got to know what
to do with them you got to know how to
make them work in order to get what you
want knowing that you're the best at
what you do and you've done all your
homework to get to that point relentless
is about trusting your instincts but the
only way you can trust your instincts is
if you've done your homework and your
skill is so finely tuned at whatever you
do people in sports you have the role
players and they're trying to step out
and be superstars and i just i always
tell them i said
you got to think about winning first
all right if the team wins
you'll get paid if the team doesn't win
you will not get paid
okay
the bottom line is the end
result
just like when you guys close a deal
not only do you win
everybody underneath you who helps you
close the deal the company it all ties
in together decide
commit
act succeed
repeat the one thing that all the greats
have in common is they sweat the small
stuff they pay very very close attention
to every detail michael used to sweat
the details so much in his basketball
game that carried on into his personal
life the suit had to match the car he
was driving that particular day but what
those details allowed him to do
was to put him in the zone to be the
best basketball player on that given
night the dark side is something that's
in everybody but it's a situation that
you have to control the dark side if it
controls you that's when things start to
go real real bad that's when you have a
tendency to go to the uh what i call the
other side but if you harness the fuel
that's from that dark side whether it's
anger whether it's fear and turn that
into positive fuel it'll help you really
succeed at whatever you're trying to do
a great leader knows how to push buttons
how to push the buttons of different
people i totally disagree with that
philosophy 100 percent
all right i don't want to have somebody
to have that much control over me where
they're pushing my buttons
as a great leader
okay what i do with my clients is i pull
their buttons
and then i teach them
in certain situations to know when to
push their own buttons well you have to
keep yourself focused on whatever your
ultimate goal is their stumble their
stumbling blocks all the way people get
laid off you have a bad game you get
traded from a team that you don't want
to be with but if your goal and your
focus remains the same that hey this is
going to happen and i know i have the
skills and i have the knowledge and have
the instincts to dig myself out of this
hole you will dig yourself out of the
hole you have to control the situation
don't let the situation control you talk
about coolers we talk about closers and
we talk about cleaners cleaner is going
to get you that end result over and over
again they are so well prepared
and their instincts are so sharp
they already know what to do if there's
a person that's producing
exceptionally there's a reason behind
it's the process
constant challenge
to get there
again
and again and again
is what drives these individuals
everyone talks about we want to be
legendary
we want to be iconic don't settle for
legendary when i started studying
everyone says oh you're going to be a
gym teacher i said no i said i'm going
to work with professional athletes i
knew what i wanted to do i said i'm
going to work with i'm going to work
with professional athletes so that was
my that was the goal i set in my mind
and i just said hey that that's going to
take a place in my head
that's the only thing that i want to do
and i got to figure out a way i got to
figure out a way to get there so i
studied and learned my craft better than
anybody else did i start with the
professional athletes no after i
graduated i went to work in a local
health club
really i knew how i knew everything from
a book standpoint but still you got to
know how to apply it
okay so i
you know worked with anybody i could any
these are not pros these aren't pros i'm
talking about housewives i'm talking
about individuals that just want to get
in uh just want to get in shape people
that have had injuries from different
sports kids anybody just kind of
developing programs putting implementing
what i've learned and actually being
able to apply it and once i started to
look at that craft i said okay now i'm
starting to figure out
how to how to actually apply this stuff
and how to use it and put the formulas
together and put the workouts together
and do all these different things i mean
stuff that
they're doing now from a workout
standpoint i was doing 30 years ago wow
i mean some of the stuff is you i it's
different i stay on top of it right all
right i got to continue to learn you
know continue to be uh
better myself so i can better my
athletes better my craft but
it's a different it's just a different
way of doing the same different way of
doing the same thing
right now there's a lot more resources a
lot more education a lot more testing
available back then you kind of had to
just figure it out a lot of individuals
now okay especially in this generation
not only from a training standpoint but
from a knowledge standpoint they're
jumping from one thing to another you
know they're using this trainer this
week they're using another trainer next
week you know they're they're using this
person as a mentor on youtube then
they're using this person over here okay
and they're getting all this conflicting
information okay
you gotta you gotta master what you're
going to master
okay you have to fit you have to figure
it out too many people are jumping from
place to place to place michael kobe all
these individuals they mastered
one aspect of the game when they
mastered that aspect of the game then
they moved to another aspect of the game
when people become successful okay they
always say i don't do that anymore well
what do you mean you don't do that
anymore you should do that and then
something
like what do you mean you don't do that
anymore the most successful people
know and can do it all all right can do
it all okay
michael you know what he never when he
played
he would go around pick up the towels in
the gym after practice put the
basketball really put the basket put the
basketball michael jordan michael jordan
kobe did the same thing put the
basketballs away all right
do it just do whatever is what i was
supposed to do he that he packed us uh
got his own game gear together you know
now people have these stylists and so
forth they put their clothes together
michael put his own stuff together he's
just like handled his own tickets kobe
did the same thing so it's just like hey
just because i'm now the superstar
all right i still wanted i still have to
do the things that got me there because
it reminds me wow of what i did and what
it took to get to to get to this level
everyone's going to hit adversity yep
okay everyone's going to hit adversity
it's how you deal with adversity and the
key word is you not letting somebody
else deal with that adversity
you have to deal with adversity and how
you deal with it are you going to fight
through it or are you going to curl up
and just roll over into the corner it's
going to pretty much determine
how the rest of your development from a
mental standpoint
is going to carry you you know people
talk about this uh
people talk about this all the time you
know
losing bill's character okay well how
much character do you need
seriously all right
you know you want to keep losing and
losing listen i'd rather have a person
win who has a little bit who has a
little bit of character okay who's a
little nuts and a person that loses all
the time and he's got he's got great
character at some point you got to start
you got to start winning you can't
always look for other people to help you
other people got their own problems they
got their own they got to deal with
they're trying to achieve their own
goals they're will they are willing to
assist but after a while okay
if you constantly
looking for a system constantly looking
for help it's it's on you your failure
and your success
is on you dealing in sports you have a
lot of people in business they're
successful for themselves yeah okay or
the team they put up great numbers but
the team never wins
all right you know in business when the
owner or the ceo when he wins if he's a
cleaner
everybody in that business from the top
person all the way down to the last
person they all win
when sports if you can you bring out the
best out of all your teammates you
elevate not only your teammates you
invest you elevate the equipment matter
you elevate the equipment manager the
staff the people you have no idea the
people that handle the tickets
everybody's game is elevated because
they have to because the cleaner is not
going to come down to your level you got
to come up to theirs so when you're
choosing somebody when you choose
somebody to listen to and you choose
somebody to learn from and you choose a
business partner you choose a client
they got to be as crazy and they got to
be as [ __ ] up as you are that's how
you get success that's how you know
you're going to be able to push that
individual that's how you know that
relationship is going to last you know
people talk about in business or think
oh you got to find a balance you got to
find that person you know if you're one
way you got to find a person that's the
other way no that's
that's pulling you away from how you
want to do things and how if you're
intense the next person i want is to be
as super intense super intense now those
people around you they got to be smarter
than you are right you don't want to
surround yourself with people that if
you're the smartest person in the room
you need to get more people in the room
sure okay you should not walk into a
room and ever be the smartest person in
there okay the people around you have to
be much smarter or at least in certain
things you may have an expertise in one
thing but that other individual better
have an expertise that's beyond yours in
something in something else right but
from the mind standpoint you know mj was
just as [ __ ] up as i was kobe was just
as [ __ ] up as i was from from being
the best okay i wanted to be the best at
what i do they wanted to be the best at
what they do
all right it was an attraction it's an
attraction and those are the people that
allow you to push them and allow them to
they understand they want to get they
want to get better you know they don't
need to be motivated okay they're like
you tell them hey that's so interesting
they're not they're not hiring you to
come motivate me nobody want it as bad
as you they want the best of the best
already want it more than anybody else
there's a reason they're the best you
know we we talked about this earlier at
lunch they're the ones that are show up
to practice early okay they're the ones
taking the extra shots they're the ones
doing the wind sprints at the end
they're the ones you know getting
treatment taking care of their body
they're showing up they're showing up on
off days you're saying you're sending
the guys home you're saying you've got
to go home you got to go home
you got to literally you got to you got
to tell them to leave you don't have to
tell them to show up you got to tell
them to leave that that that that's
enough you know you have people in your
office you look at it you know how many
employees do you have now we got 4 200
agents 4 200 agents okay our 4 200
agents okay if you put them all in all
in the room okay and you were able to
put them all in one shop together all
right and say your hours were nine to
five
okay you'd have 4 200 people in here
from nine from nine to five o'clock from
five o'clock after five o'clock
you may have five hundred after seven
o'clock
you may have two hundred
after nine o'clock you may have five and
then guess what at the end of the day
there's gonna be one light left on maybe
two yours and somebody else's that
person's as [ __ ] up as you are
right but you can count on that
individual you can count on that
individual so we're both workout guys we
like to go to that we like we like to go
to the gym all right
how many times have you seen people in
the gym they spend more time on their
playlist
taking pictures doing stuff instead of
getting their work instead of getting
their work out done so true it's just
like you know and here's the thing all
right you're a very intense person i can
tell right okay i'm a very intense
person all right we value our time yes
okay
how do you get results in the gym it
isn't about spending two to three hours
working out people say i spent three
hours you didn't spend three hours you
by time you pulled into the parking lot
by the time you changed got some
breakfast put your workout clothes on
talk to eight people did all that stuff
you were there for you were there for
three hours you did you you did you you
did your three hours
no intensity yeah all right all right
people talk about hey
you know you post a couple of workout
things you see you're a buff guy or
you're next you're in great shape all
right people say
and i want to look i want to look like
you all right
they don't see what it takes to look
like you not only in the gym
outside of the gym the intensity that's
there you're in the gym and i'm assuming
you work out with music you had some
headphones on you got to get a certain
amount of stuff done in a certain amount
of time or you're in this intensive
somebody comes up to you yeah
okay and you don't want to be rude to
them so you die you take your headphones
off they ask you a question they want to
take a picture with you oh i recognize
you from so and so on all right and then
the question is how do i get to look
like well the one way you get to look
like me is leave me that for long
and start hitting start hitting the
weights start start lifting it's
the intensity that you have it has to be
in everything you do you have to be an
intense person in your workouts the way
you the way you eat okay that's that's
intensity how do how do you fuel up your
metabolism rates so you're burning these
calories so you can get that definition
that's intense that's an intensity how
do you get to be successful you know oh
man he he or she he's so intense no you
know what
he and she
that's how you're supposed to be you're
at a different level right and that's
why i said the intensity is so it's so
important it's what really separates
those individuals and you can't get into
that zone and you can't get
arms
and abs like ed all right you can't do
it unless you have that intensity and
you're willing to block out the
distractions
we have so much access now to
information yep it's literally at our
fingertips you know everything okay
why are more individuals doing less
relentless is more than just a mindset
it's a skill set it's a mindset it's a
way to kick ass we talk about kicking
ass and taking names well when you're
relentless you've kicked so much ass you
can't remember all the names because it
becomes irrelevant the name that they
remember is your name that's what
relentless is being about it's not about
others it's about yourself it's about
taking yourself to a level that only few
people can achieve the mindset is
completely different it's about
capturing other people's hearts and not
letting them go
it's learning to step on their throat
it's about killing the competition your
fiercest competitors are cutthroat
individuals all they want to do is win
and they want to win over and over again
it's not just a one-time thing success
is repeated many many times you can have
a skill set to do a lot of things okay
you can train you can read a manual you
can do all these different things but a
skill set only works if you have that
mindset everyone talks about i got
passion i got inner drive you know what
passion inner drive is it's absolutely
nothing unless there's a action a
relentless action that follows it and if
you have that relentless action that
follows your passion that follows that
inner drive you have then you get that
end result how many times have you
watched sports and they said the
person's thinking too much
stop thinking stop thinking just go out
just go out and play well what happens
when you tell an individual to stop
thinking what's the first thing they do
they start thinking exactly
do you know how many hours and years of
preparation
go into not being able to not to think
about something
like
it takes
years and years and years of doing the
same
thing
over and over and over again
okay
learn how not to think not to think wow
to be able to take a to take a reaction
and turn it into a reflex
that's what the greatest can do most
people react to things okay the greatest
it's it's an instinct it's it's
impulsive it's innate
it becomes a it becomes a reflex you
know we talk about this listen
trust your instincts that's what closers
do you know what cleaners do their
instincts trust them
i got this i'll give you a great example
about that and we'll pick up the other
thing all right
doug collins
coach of the bulls yep he's drawing up
this play okay last second play he's
drawn it's the cleveland play the one he
beat uh
right yep so he's drawing up all he's
drawing up this play all this other
stuff he's over he raises it michael
turns around and said hey give me the
ball get out the way
in the timeout yeah after the time you
know before doggies goes give me the
ball get the [ __ ] out the way
okay
that's that's the don't think okay
that's the point where hey listen
my instincts trust me give me the ball
just get the hell out the way i'm
winning this game
i'm winning this game but that
game-winning shot
wasn't made there it was made many years
before
in the you know in the dark gym by
himself with somebody rebounding the
ball whether it was me or somebody else
shooting that same shot over and over
and over and over again saying if i get
to this spot i don't care if there's 10
hands in front of me if i get to this
spot the shot's going in because i've
done it over and over again just for a
second because this just blew my mind is
your dad that come from india right yes
and your dad um you're in the cab
you just get here you're in the kitchen
yep and my mom's already here okay
establish herself as a nurse and
well my dad
it was easier for my it was easier for
my mom to get her license here as a
nurse practitioner that was for my dad
to get his license as a as a doctor
all right an md
and he wasn't able to get it wasn't able
to get the license we still came over
we're sitting in the cab and he's
counting the money and the meter gets to
i forget what the number was and my dad
tells a cab driver stop
and you're a little boy right a little
boy yeah i was four years old
he said stop
and we're like what's going on
and my dad goes hey listen we're in a
new country i want you to enjoy the
scenery so we get out we grab all the
luggage excuse me get real emotional
it's awesome
and we're walking down the street
that's awesome brother
you got it
yeah
we're walking down the street with his
luggage
and he's showing us a different scenery
and so forth
never knew he didn't have any more money
in his pocket wow
wow
amazing
but he got us here got you there that's
so powerful you imagine that little boy
walking down that street turns out to be
you
and amazing your dad sewing those seeds
into you and there's moments like that
that define you
as long as you remember them they can
define you both ways
you can look at it and say you know what
you can use that as an excuse my dad
came to this country he didn't have any
money he never gave me anything he never
did this and people do that or you can
look at it and say he gave us everything
winning is not about
the trophy and the accolades
it's about the grind
it's about the obstacles it's about the
challenges it's about the pain
that you endure along the way
for that 30 seconds
of being able to either
stand on the platform
be acknowledged by
individuals that are close to you
but when that happens
your mind has to immediately shift back
because now
you felt and tasted something
that you could only get through winning
are you willing to do it again winning
is in all of us
we all want to win
but the path people take
to get to winning
everybody wants the end result and they
want to feel the sugar and the the
the confetti and all that other stuff
but what you have to endure to win no
one wants to talk about
and that's what really winning is about
because you spend more time
enduring it
and being in a pl and not in a good
place
and i wanted to bring it out and say hey
no matter what you do in life where
you're at
this is what
winning takes and it's in all of us
it's in all of us you find wins every
single day do you think anyone can
become a winner winning isn't all of us
that's what i would say listen and we
have wins every single moment and those
are the steps that get us a little
closer to what we want we have a stat we
every minute you have an opportunity to
win you really do but with everything
that went on in the world in this past
year
people forgot how to win people don't
even know what a win looks like anymore
what does it look like yeah people don't
even know like
and so many times a win just comes by
because there's a constant change
there's a constant shift and now with
the paradigm of way everything is being
handled now
you have to look at things completely
different everybody's waiting for normal
a win
a win doesn't look like what it used to
look like anymore right
all right what does it look like now
what does it look like now for each
individual it's different
for each individual it's different for a
lot of individuals it's just like
getting out of that routine that you
were stuck in for so long
and did the pandemic allow you to say
you know what yeah i was in a routine
but the routine wasn't getting me
anywhere i was in a routine of comfort
and the pandemic put a lot of people in
a routine that was very uncomfortable
that they weren't used to
they weren't but it was a necessity it
was needed
you know people always wish for this
time
during this thing that happened
i want to spend more time with my family
and now they have it now you have it
okay
schools aren't doing a good job with
with educating my kids
now you're homeschooled all right i'd
love to work from the house
now you're doing it
now you're doing it now you have all
these things going on that you wished
you had as you thought were wins and for
some people they were
and for others you're just like no
these were not these are not wins
these aren't
i do a lot of zoom stuff at home
and i got a cat and i got a very lively
dog and you'll see the cat run right
right across the screen of course i
don't have little kids in the house
anymore
but trying to work
and have them in the background
asking for school help or you know
they're they're on their bandwidth
trying to study in their school stuff
and
winning became a distraction
it became a distraction
and people were trying to balance all
these different things and forgot hey
this is what my win is
that you need to recognize what that win
is now and during the pandemic it's not
getting back to normal
it's getting beyond normal
figuring out what your next win is
how to place it and how to continue to
move forward on that win yeah
because it's easy to talk about the
setbacks because so many people can
relate to that that gave us a nice
little comfort thing everybody can use
the pandemic as an excuse
yeah all right and then you have other
people that thrive during that time
they're like
i got
i got to find out a new way to win
[Music]
i got to find out like a real real new
way to win and you had some people that
really really won big during that time
absolutely they stepped up they they
stepped up yes
they stepped up they saw the steps
and i was like okay
are these steps stable are they unstable
it doesn't matter i got a climber life
and winning
is a bunch of sprints within a marathon
you know that's a fact yeah a bunch of
sprints within a marathon and you can't
see the end line like in a marathon you
know where the end line is in winning
that win
that race may have an end line
but there's another start line right
after it yeah for people that are really
driven and this is just this is not
about money and this isn't about fame
this is about you could be winning as a
school teacher you'd be winning as an
entrepreneur you could be winning in
business you could be winning as an
athlete as a waiter whatever it is a
waitress whatever it is it's that every
single time you sprint to that finish
line
there's another start line that's coming
and that's why it never ends it's a
marathon that just keeps going going and
going and i try to tell people listen
i'm not an avid runner i used to be in
my much younger days not avid i used to
enjoy it
you see the times
of the
the best marathons they're running
insane
insane they say they're basically
sprinting they they're basically they're
they're sprinting everyone looks at the
physical condition
are you mentally prepared to sprint
every single day
are you mentally prepared to sprint
every single day and for how long
because
somebody else is sprinting
you don't want them to get
what be what should be your win
ends up being somebody else's win reason
i know so much about winning is because
i've had to deal with so much losing
that's interesting what do you mean by
that everybody wants to win but in order
to know how to win
you got to know how to lose because
you're going to lose more than you're
going to win
but every time you lose what do you gain
from it
so every time i've lost
people say you got to jump right back up
you know get back right on your feet
again and i i disagree with that
after you lose
or when you get knocked down
stay down there for a minute
understand why you lost
what were the reasons why are you down
here why did you lose
why did you get knocked down
because if you just jump right back up
you're going to lose again
and again and you're continually going
to lose the same way so every time i
lost
i stayed down for a second
minutes
hours
days
weeks
but when i stood up i was different
i was smarter
and when i lost again
i stayed down
i stood back up i was stronger
when i lost again
i stayed down
how did i stand up again i was more
confident
lost again
stood up
i was more resilient
now you start putting the pieces that
are necessary to win over and over and
over again
so if you lose and you jump right back
up and you haven't really changed i mean
really really changed from that loss
you're never going to learn from it and
you're never going to really truly know
the unforgiving
race to greatness because that's the
that's part of the unforgiving part is
the losing part that part is unforgiving
you just don't win
in one arena
you win in your sports
you win in business you win in your
personal life
other people win because you win
it isn't just about you
it's about being able to pull the team
and
show them the what it feels like to win
and what kind of feeling that gives and
when you win your family wins
when your family wins you win when you
win your friends win the people that
have supported you
every time michael played i always said
this i said and i said this in the last
dance
he would say
these individuals are giving me
something
that's
way more valuable
than the price of a ticket
they're giving me their time
which is non-refundable
which is not you can't exchange it with
somebody else you can't take your ticket
and exchange it with another individual
these people are literally giving me
their time whether they're at the arena
they're sitting in front of tv
they're watching the news listening to
it on the radio back then whatever
whatever it may be
accountability to myself and those
individuals
has to be at the highest level
has to be at the highest level because
they're doing something
that is so giving me something that's so
valuable
i have to
yeah be at my best people
they look at winning
and finishing as the same those
individuals that you're talking about
they're just looking to finish they're
just looking to finish their career
they're like okay this is what i got
this nice house i'm finished over here i
made the nba or made the end of that
that's finishing and a lot of people to
that
like
they feel like if they finish they've
won
these individuals
it's a completely different it's a
completely different level so you have
individuals that go out and run
marathons you know
if you compete at the highest level and
you're
a person that just runs marathon the
chances of you winning that marathon are
pretty much zero
but you're going to finish that marathon
but being able to finish that marathon
puts you in a mindset to win at
something else
so there's always what's next what's
next what's the next thing that's going
on you know we talk about what kobe one
of his biggest lines
is you know
don't rest in the middle
rest at the end
winners rest at the end
when you talk about fit people that just
want to finish
just what you said they rest in the
middle winning is not supposed to be
fair life is not fair there's nothing
that's going to guarantee you that
win it's but the only thing that's going
to guarantee you that loss is if you
don't get in this race how many people
and you talk about this all the time
about the fears and the emotions and
like you know just
getting just going for it just like here
it is
look at yourself
you've moved
three different times in
probably the last six months
for whatever reasons you've had
all right
and
you've literally packed up and moved
like here i'm going here i'm going here
you got people that
won't move themselves out of a chair
you've literally moved families lives
played
and there's literally a fear behind
every single one of those but there's no
doubt so what they're seeing when they
look in the mirror they're just trying
to see what's on the surface but winning
and losing wants to know what's inside
of you it wants to know what makes you
tick it wants to know what your desires
are wants to know what your ego is it
wants to know what your limitations are
it wants to know what your mindset is it
wants to know everything about you
because winning does not lie when you
look in the mirror
you can lie and see what's on the
surface you cannot lie what's going on
inside
and that's what people are not willing
to see the lies that are truly going on
inside of them that are not allowing
them to win over and over sometimes even
win once
you have to look winning requires you to
go so far deep inside yourself
it's way beyond the surface it's way
beyond internal it's going to a place
that
a lot of people haven't visited in a
long long time because they're afraid to
visit that person because when they
visit that person
they don't know who that person is
anymore in the book kobe said he said
winning is everything
it's everything
all right
and you sit here and you talk talk to
mike whatever kobe would say
mike would have to one-up them
because they're still the competition
never stops it's always about what's
next what can i what can i win more at
you know both those individuals you know
obviously kobe's not with us anymore but
both those individuals
the competition and the desire
and the feeling of winning even though
they were done with playing
manifested into something else
you know mj
the most successful
sneaker brand out there
all right
owning a team
tequila business
um
in the sports gambling business he's in
all those things
he's in all those things
all right so the competition never stops
with kobe it was like i'm going to win
an oscar go out and win an oscar
writing children's writing children's
book he was literally his goal
he would his plan was to take over
hollywood
he was like i owned la on the basketball
court
and now i want to own
la he wanted to take that was his
winning thing
take the basketball out of it everyone
knows i own l.a on the basketball court
and we talked about this he goes
own la
own la and if you look at the paths he
was going through
that's what he that's what he was doing
that's what he was that was his and that
was his next definition of win if you
want more inspiration morning videos
they're not on this channel anymore i
have a dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe and i'll see
you there